WILL: WELL, WE WERE PROMISED
TRANSPARENCY ON DAY ONE OF THE
BIDEN WHITE HOUSE AS THE PRESS
DEMANDS ACCESS TO THE
UNPRECEDENTED SITUATION AT THE
BORDER THEY CONTINUE TO BE
DENIED.
>> WE’LL ALWAYS BE HONEST AND
TRANSPARENT WITH YOU ABOUT BOTH
THE GOOD NEWS AND THE BAD FROM
IF YOU ALL WANTED TO GRANT
ACCESS TO THE PRESS, COULDN’T
YOU JUST TELL DHS TO DO IT.
>> AGAIN, WE FULLY SUPPORT
TRANSPARENCY AND I WOULD
ENCOURAGE TO YOU TALK TO THE
TEMPT OF HOMELAND SECURITY ABOUT
ANY REQUESTS THAT YOU HAVE.
>> WE ARE WORKING ON PROVIDING
FOOTAGE SO THAT THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC CAN SEE THE BORDER PATROL
STATIONS.
THE BORDER IS SECURE.
THE BORDER IS CLOSED.
WILL: WE ARE WORKING ON
PROVIDING FOOTAGE.
WHAT A STUNNING STATEMENT RIGHT
THERE.
SENIOR WRITER FOR TOWN HALL.COM
JULIO WILL BE ON THE GROUND
VISITING THE TEXAS BORDER THIS
WEEK.
HE JOINS ME NOW.
START RIGHT THERE, JULIO.
THERE ARE REPORTEDLY VERY LITTLE
ALLOWANCES FOR THE PRESS TO GET
IN THERE AND SEE WHAT’S
HAPPENING AT THE BORDER BECAUSE
DON’T WORRY BECAUSE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS GOING TO
PROVIDE YOU SOME FOOTAGE.
THEY ARE WORKING ON IT BUT
EVENTUALLY PROVIDE YOU FOOTAGE.
DO YOU THINK THAT WILL SATISFY
YOUR CURIOSITY, JULIO.
>> NO.
IN FACT, I WAS SUPPOSED TO GO
VISIT THE SPRINGS FACILITY FOR
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS AND ALL SET
UP THROUGH CONGRESSMAN ROY’S
OFFICE AND I WAS GIFT AGREEMENT
AND ONCE WE GOT THERE WE WERE
STARTING THE PROCESS TO GET LET.
IN TEMPERATURE CHECK AND MEDICAL
GRADE FACE MASKS ISSUED TO US
AND WAITING TO GET OUR COVID
TESTS THAT’S WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN USING
BAR TESTS BECAUSE OF CODE
RESTRICTIONS.
THEY FOUND OUT WE WERE MEMBERS
OF THE PRESS AND IMMEDIATELY
DIVIDED AND ORDERED TO LEAF.
USING COVID-19 AS A PRETEXT TO
KEEP PRESS OUT IT.
APPEARS MEMBERS OF CONGRESS AND
THEIR STAFF ARE ABLE TO TOUR THE
FACILITY.
WILL: YOU WERE PART OF A
CONGRESSIONAL DELEGATION, MEDIA
MEMBER CONGRESSIONAL CONSCIOUS
CARVED OUT OF THE TOURING PARTY
REPORTEDLY OR WHAT THEY TOLD YOU
FOR COVID PROTECTIVE REASONS BUT
THEN THEY LET THE CONGRESSIONAL
DELEGATION GO ON.
THEY WERE ALLOWED TO CONTINUE
THE TOUR.
BUT THE MEDIA WERE THE ONES THAT
THEY HAD TO PROTECT FROM COVID
PROBLEMS.
>> RIGHT.
AND, LOOK, IT’S PRETTY OBVIOUS
WHY THE ADMINISTRATION DOESN’T
WANT MEMBERS OF THE PRESS TO
DOCUMENT FOR THEMSELVES WHAT’S
HAPPENING IN THESE FACILITIES
AND ELSEWHERE ALONG THE BORDER.
JUST SIMPLY BECAUSE THIS IS A
CRISIS AND WHAT MAKES IT WORSE
IS THAT THIS IS A SELF-INFLICTED
CRISIS.
THIS DIDN’T NEED TO HAPPEN.
BUT PAUSE OF THE OPEN BORDER
RHETORIC AND POLICIES THAT WE
HAVE SEEN FROM THIS
ADMINISTRATION IT HAS
INCENTIVIZED THIS MASSIVE SURGE.
IT’S NOT THE ONLY REASON WHY IT
IS A BIG REASON.
LAST OCTOBER I WAS WITH ACTING
COMMISSIONER MARK MORGAN DOING A
RIDE ALONG WITH HIM.
EVEN IN THE AGE OF COVID, RIDE
ALONGS WITH BORDER PATROL IS
STILL POSSIBLE AND YET THAT’S
NOT BEING ALLOWED RIGHT NOW.
WILL: AS WE SAID AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE SEGMENT YOU ARE
HEADED BACK TO THE BORDER NEXT
WEEK THIS IS POTENTIALLY AT
LEAST WHAT YOU WILL SEE IN
NUMBERS.
HERE IS THE INCREASE IN ADULT
QUOTE ENCOUNTERS.
THAT’S THE NEW TERM UNDER THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION ENCOUNTERS
UP 188%.
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS UP 92%.
WHAT ARE YOU EXPECTING TO SEE
NOT JUST IN NUMBERS BUT WITH
YOUR OWN EYES NEXT WEEK?
>> UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE SEEING UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS AND FAMILY UNITS BECAUSE
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY SECRETARY HAS SAID THAT
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO DEPORT
THOSE TYPES OF GROUPS LIKE THEY
USED TO.
AND SO THAT, AGAIN, THAT’S
INCENTIVIZING HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AMONG THE MOST VULNERABLE GROUPS
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS.
THE CARTELS AREN’T DOING THIS
OUT OF THE KINDNESS OF THEIR
HEARTS.
THEY TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
PEOPLE THEY TRAFFIC ESPECIALLY
THE MINORS.
WHAT I SAW TWO WEEKS AGO AND
WHAT I EXPECT TO SEE THIS WEEK
IS MOSTLY UNACCOMPANIED MINORS
AND FAMILY UNITS.
LIKE I SAID THIS, IS A CRISIS.
WILL: YOUR RIDE ALONG THIS
COMING WEEK CONSTABLE SO YOU
SHOULD GET TO SEE EXACTLY WHAT’S
HAPPENING DOWN THERE.
LOVE TO TALK TO YOU AFTERWARDS
JULIO.